Je suis vraiment désolé que cette vidéo arrive en retard je crois que je suis après tout le monde
mais cette vidéo, ça fait un moment que je suis dessus, j'ai eu pas mal de contretemps... bref désolé
Enfin la voilà !
je peine encore à croire que la suite de breath of the wild ait été annoncé et c'est vraiment juste incroyable
comme je l'affirmais dans mon trois théories sur Zelda, je suis un vrai passionné de zelda, tous les jours je bouquine hyrule histo...
Mec faut qu't'arrêtes avec cette histoire de bouquiner hyrule historia tous les jours personne ne fait ça
Euh... Ouais d'accord... Donc oui il y a Iro dans la vidéo j'ai oublié de le préciser
Comme vous le voyez je ne suis pas seul, vous allez voir une vidéo vraiment 100% subjective et qui est travaillée depuis...
...La sortie du trailer mais auquel j'avais eu beaucoup d'examens, Bref encore désolé du retard
C'est clair qu'on a attendu mec ! Bon bah on commence où on attend que impa meurt de vieillesse ?
P*tain Iro ! Bon bref cette vidéo va être compliqué je le sens... Allez, générique !
A l'heure actuelle ce n'est plus vraiment une théorie et même sans avoir confirmation il était très facile de s'en douter
Ganondorf est de retour à notre plus grande surprise !
Effectivement, la momie qui se réveille à la fin du trailer est bel et bien ganondorf, l'ennemi juré du royaume d'Hyrule et de l'élu
A titre personnel, je trouve ça réellement incroyable que ganondorf sonit de retour et cela va impliquer du lourd... du très lourd...
Déjà, comment prouver pour certains que nous sommes bel et bien en face à Ganondorf ?
Ce dernier possède une chevelure rougeoyante qui nous rappelle très fortement le dernier design appliqué à Ganondorf dans Hyrule Warriors
Ses bijoux Gerudo, l'ornement qu'il posséde dans Ocarina of Time,  Twilight Princess, Wind Waker et j'en passe...
Déjà, nous sommes face à un Gerudo.
Enfin, la peinture sur le meilleur représentant Ganondorf à cheval et avec un trident souligne encore plus la chose... Bref c'est ganondorf
Dernièrement, les glyphes guirado présent dans le trailer ont affirmé de par leur traduction le retour du seigneur du mal avec pour signification : "Sceau Ganon"
La première théorie et la deuxième théorie seront plus ou moins liés dans leur histoire mais j'aimerais pour commencer calmement...
...Réagir et faire une réflexion sur le retour de cet antagoniste et notamment par rapport à Breath Of The Wild, premier du nom
Nous voyons actuellement dans le trailer que le sceau retenant Ganondorf est sur le point de se briser
Une grande puissance malveillante émane du corps momifié et je pense à titre personnel que cela fait un moment que le sceau est sur le point de se briser
Je dirais un peu plus de 100 ans
Effectivement dans Breath Of The Wild, le boss de fin est Ganon le Fléau avec un visuel très spectral
Pour aller droit au but je pense très sincèrement que Botw nous proposait comme ennemi une projection de Ganondorf en Ganon
Idée accentuée par les déclarations du roi je cite : "Le monstre retrouvera sa forme originelle et s'abattra sur Hyrule de toute sa puissance"
Ganondorf dans Botw était encore sous l'emprise du sceau, l'empêchant de pouvoir se mouvoir et d'agir
Sa projection dans Breath of the Wild servait justement à pouvoir revenir et en massacrant tout le monde...
...Avoir le terrain libre pour se libérer de son sceau et recouvrer toute sa puissance
Ce qui me fait penser ceci également et que le roi affirme que : "C'est au sein même du royaume d'Hyrule que Ganon le Fléau a vu le jour, il y a bien des siècles"
Plusieurs choses sont intéressantes là dedans... Mais pour le moment, un détail nous intéresse
Il est souligné dans ses paroles que Ganondorf, il y a 100 ans était déjà sous le château d'hyrule à sommeiller, je le comprends comme ceci
Et justement, la salle où est enfermé Ganondorf est rempli de pics rocheux. Pics que nous retrouvons autour du château lorsque le Fléau est réapparu il y a 100 ans
De par la position des pics, nous avons l'impression qu'ils ont émané de la où Ganondorf se trouvait : Sous le château
Ceci prouve pour moi son intérêt et sa projection par le biais du sceau qui s'affaiblit de jour en jour
Alors oui, nous devons parler du temps.
Ce n'est pas montrer explicitement mais le fait que Ganondorf soit une momie n'est vraiment pas anodin
Il se pourrait et cela en est même certain, Ganondorf moisit sous le château d'Hyrule, scellé
depuis plus de 10 000 ans, Pourquoi cela ?
Déjà, nous pouvons faire le rapprochement avec les moines Sheikah présents dans Breath of the Wild. ces derniers sont présents également depuis cette période...
Comme nous le montre la légende présenté par Impa.
De plus le choix de la momie souligne l'ancienneté comme un pharaon dans son tombeau
Un code visuellement important
Enfin, la peinture sur le mur avec une représentation d'un Ganondorf au plus haut de sa forme nous montre l'évolution du personnage
Mais également une mise en garde de là où vous mettez les pieds.
Nous sommes dans le sanctuaire renfermant Ganondorf
D'ailleurs, les dessins sur les murs ont la même signification que la momification : "L'ancienneté"
Mais du coup si Ganondorf est toujours présent et ce depuis 10 000 ans, que s'est il passé réellement ?
N'avait-il pas été vaincu en deux coups de cuillère à pot normalement ?
Effectivement nous sommes sur une suite de Breath of the wild, un jeu qui se déroulera après ce que nous avons connu dans le premier opus, comme il nous l'a été déclaré
Néanmoins, paradoxalement ce sera un jeu qui pourrait être intimement liée à ce qu'il s'est passé avant breath of the wild, 10 000 ans auparavant. Je m'explique...
Nous sommes obligés de remémorer le passé notamment par la présence de Ganondorf sommeillant depuis plus de 10 000 ans à cause du sceau
En parlant du sceau, tiens...
De par sa couleur, la forme des particules...
Nous ne pouvons nous empêcher de lier ceci à la légende d'Impa avec l'ancien héros qui vaincu Ganondorf autrefois
Soit un élément de plus nous reliant à cette période
Il se pourrait et cela en est même certain que la main retenant Ganondorf soit celle du héros de jadis permettant d'emprisonner le démon
Cette idée est accentuée par le fait que link semble intimement lié dans le trailer au pouvoir retenant Ganondorf
Au point même de l'absorber, ce qui ferait probablement "Upgrade" ses pouvoirs.
Le pouvoir de deux héros dans le corps d'un seul...
L'idée me plaît mais il n'y aurait-il pas
un conflit temporel ? je m'égare...
Mais... Tous ces détails m'empêchent d'y voir clair... Il manque des réponses...
Dans l'histoire et la légende présentée par Impa, cette dernière nous affirme que le héros et la princesse n'étaient pas seuls...
Mais accompagnés des gardiens et des créatures divines et donc qu'ils ont brillamment vaincu Ganon sans réelle difficulté
pourquoi Ganondorf est-il toujours en vie 10 000 ans plus tard ?
Et pourquoi avoir enterré les créatures divines ainsi que les gardiens puisque ils ont l'air si formidable dans Botw ?
...Même après la défaite de Ganon le fléau.
Ce que je veux dire c'est que Impa elle-même sait que l'histoire Ganon et de la famille royale est intimement liée
...Et que l'histoire se répète donc encore et encore....
Alors pourquoi avoir mis de côté les créatures depuis tout ce temps ?
Et surtout comment se fait-il qu'Impa en sache autant sur l'histoire d'hyrule
Et du retour incessant de Ganon ?
Que s'est il réellement passé au final il y a 10 000 ans ?
C'est la question que je me pose aujourd'hui
Il se pourrait, et cela en est même presque sûr que tout ne s'est pas si bien passé que comme Impa nous le raconte
Vaincre Ganondorf n'est pas chose aisée et si l'histoire n'est donc pas conclue 10 000 ans plus tard...
C'est que beaucoup de non-dits sont présents et signent un second retour de ganondorf
J'attends des réponses concernant ce breath of the wild 2, sur le passé de breath of the wild comme il est démontré dans ce trailer
Inclure ganondorf dans l'histoire de breath of the wild inclut forcément du Lore
Et comme Impa nous raconte la légende nous avons l'impression qu'elle-même a connaissance de la malédiction lancée par l'Avatar du Néant
Mais... Recentrons-nous !
J'aimerais accentuer une autre partie du sujet
Le coup des créatures divines est quelque chose de réellement mystérieux...
Dans Breath of the wild, à plusieurs reprises, on nous montre que les créatures divines étaient bonne pour le peuple
Qu'elles protégeaientt ces derniers et vivaient en harmonie avec.
C'est même souligné avec l'épilogue où ils cohabitent encore avec, malgré l'acte de Ganon le Fléau
Zelda souhaite d'ailleurs revoir Vah'Ruta...
Parce qu'elle semble avoir un problème...
Les créatures divines... Ont été conçues par les Sheikah...
Il y a maintenant plus de 10 000 ans et ont servi à vaincre le Fléau
Cependant... Vocah, un des Sheikah de Breath of the wild nous amène une problématique plutôt intéressante
Les Yigas sont aujourd'hui les ennemis d'Hyrule et leurs ancêtres ont fait parti des créateurs des créatures divines ainsi que des gardiens
Ces derniers savent reconnaître Link en un clin d'oeil et savent ce qui le lie au fléau : Il est l'élu
Pour continuer, ce que je trouve très pertinent
sont les dires du roi au moment où il raconte l'histoire d'il y a 100 ans à Link
Apparemment un devin est venu prévenir le royaume que Ganon allait revenir une nouvelle fois et qu'il renaîtrait au sein même du royaume d'Hyrule
Son identité est un mystère. Mais ce dernier laissait sous-entendre qu'un moyen de contrer son retour était présent dans les entrailles du château
Les créatures divines ont alors été découvertes et
4 champions ont été choisis pour les manipuler...
Ainsi qu'une armée de gardiens
Vous ne voyez pas ici quelque chose d'étrange ?...
"Le peuple d'Hyrule pris peur du peuple Sheikah à cause de leur technologie très avancée"
Et si le devin avait tendu un piège...
Effectivement Ganon a pu revenir grâce à la prise du pouvoir sur les gardiens et les créatures divines
Ganon a réussi à prendre possession de toutes les machines Sheikah avec une simplicité déconcertante
Au point même de fusionner avec cette technologie comme démontré dans l'affrontement final
Dans Breath of the Wild, l'utilisation des gardiens lors de l'affrontement final n'est qu'un bonus
La véritable arme pouvant défaire le Fléau
est bel et bien Link
Je le rappelle, mais pourquoi avoir enterré
les créatures divines il y a 10 000 ans alors que ce sont des engins si formidables ?
Et si au final, c'était tout le contraire ?
Et si au final, cela était dû à la trahison des Sheikah chassés par les Hyliens qui ont pris peur de cette nouvelle technologie avancée
Les Yigas ont aujourd'hui prêté allégeance à Ganon le Fléau et la technologie conçue par leurs ancêtres ont permis à ce dernier...
...De pouvoir écraser le royaume d'hyrule à son retour avec une grande simplicité
Il est possible qu'au final, sceller Ganondorf était pour le héros de l'époque, un moyen de pouvoir bloquer le mal à tout jamais sans le tuer
Et donc qu'il ne puisse revenir une nouvelle fois...
Mais, et si la réponse à cette problématique était bien plus sombre qu'on le pense ?
Les Yigas... La technologie Sheikah...
La peur du royaume... Les créatures divines enfouies...
Ganondorf ne semble pas être la seule source du mal...
Il était pour moi évident d'en parler,
qu'en est il de la Timeline ?
J'entends déjà certains grincer des dents mais il est vrai que c'est un sujet à débat...
Malgré l'officialisation de cette dernière par Nintendo, notamment par le biais d'Hyrule Historia et Skyward Sword
La Timeline est présente pour faire plaisir aux fans et depuis un bon moment, on nous bassine que Breath of the Wild ne fait pas parti de la Timeline
Déclaré par Aonuma lui-même, Breath of the Wild a été placé à la fin de chaque Timelines sur le site officiel de Nintendo
Pour justement souligner ce non-intérêt : La Fin de la Timeline Zelda
Mais aujourd'hui je pense le contraire
Effectivement aonuma est un petit malin et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il a tout prémédité
Pourquoi nous avoir caché le placement de Breath of the wild dans la Timeline jusqu'au point de le renier ?
Car Breath of the wild 2 peut nous apporter les réponses
Qu'est ce qui me fait penser ceci ?
Premièrement, le retour de Ganondorf.
Faire revenir l'ennemi juré et ce sous forme humaine, de Gerudo, n'est vraiment pas anodin
Ganondorf est le symbole du Lore dans Zelda
La réincarnation de l'Avatar du néant.
Le faire revenir signifie qu'il y a derrière un background historique
A contrario de Ganon qui n'est qu'une créatures des ténèbres
Bref, tout ça pour dire qu'avant en Breath of the wild, il y a une histoire encore plus complète qu'on le pense
Maintenant, tournons-nous vers la timeline.
Il est encore beaucoup trop tôt pour réellement affirmer sur où sera le placement de Botw et Botw2
Il reste possible que Nintendo reste sur des jeux
Hors-Timeline
Ou que nous sommes sur un regroupement des trois branches, au vu des nombreuses références comme :
le Miroir des Ombres, les Korogus ou la tenue des Landes
Rien qu'avec 3 "items", nous avons déjà une référence provenant de chaque Timelines
Cependant j'ai tout de même une idée qui me fait fantasmer, le détail clé : La Peinture de Ganondorf
Cette image est réellement pleine de sens.
Un dessin pareil signifie tout d'abord l'ancienneté du personnage et notamment une mise en garde
Mais le plus intéressant reste la représentation du personnage.
Ganondorf est représenté sur son cheval et il est armé d'un trident
Dans l'histoire de Zelda, il y a seulement 2 jeux où Ganondorf est un cavalier.
le 1er est Ocarina of Time donc pas très pertinent...
Car il est présent dans chaque Timeline techniquement
Mais le second jeu est Zelda Twilight Princess, c'est un indice important
Si Ganondorf est représenté sur un cheval c'est que des gens dans l'univers de breath of the wild l'ont connu en tant que cavalier
Ocarina of Time est je pense beaucoup trop loin dans le temps
En revanche, Twilight Princess est plus proche et même dans le dessin lui-même qui rappelle beaucoup le Ganondorf de TP
L'autre point est le trident !
Rien de bien fou, le trident est l'arme de prédilection de Ganon, peu importe la Timeline
Mais là où je veux en venir c'est que le dessin représente Ganondorf avec un trident sur un cheval, du jamais vu
Ce dessin serait en fait une représentation d'allah fois Ganondorf par le cheval et la forme humaine
mais aussi de Ganon par rapport au trident
Ce qui veut dire que nous sommes sur des gens qui ont connu à la fois Ganon mais aussi Ganondorf,
je crois que vous commencez à comprendre
Seule une branche nous présente à la fois Ganondorf et Ganon : la Timeline de l'enfant
Effectivement dans TP, nous sommes face à Ganondorf capable de se transformer en Ganon
Mais également, nous le combattons sur un cheval
Dans Four Swords Adventures, le Zelda qui fait suite à TP, Ganon est ressuscité et il est armé de son trident
Sans compter que Four Swords Adventures est le dernier Zelda de cette Timeline
...Et qu'il est sous-entendu que ce dernier reviendra
Et je ré-insiste sur ce détail mais le Ganondorf de cette Timeline est capable de se transformer à sa guise en Ganon
Contrairement à la Timeline de la défaite où nous sommes constamment face à la bête Ganon, dénoué de réelle intelligence
Ou encore celle de l'adulte où Ganon n'a jamais été présent
J'aimerais finir sur certains détails.
Effectivement, l'ornementation, les bijoux Gerudos rappellent le Ganondorf de Twilight Princess
Les particules bleues peuvent rappeler Midona
Ou encore pour certains, le craquement du coup dans le Trailer leur rappelle Xanto
Mais il y a encore un détail très important.
Dans la timeline de l'enfance, celle qui correspondrait, Ganondorf possède une blessure importante et très souligné dans cette branche
Son Torse !
Seulement dans cette branche, Ganondorf est blessé au torse
Et dans le trailer, par où Ganondorf est maintenu et scellé ? Par le torse !
Son unique point faible depuis de TP
Bien évidemment, tout ceci ne reste qu'une interprétation personnelle !
A vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez,
en tout cas tout semble réellement lié
J'espère vraiment que la vidéo vous aura plu, si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas à me le dire dans les commentaires...
A réagir sur les théories et me dire vos propres avis justement, à vous Abonner sur Youtube, me suivre sur Twitter, Instagram
Vous pouvez me soutenir via Utip,
Bref il y a plusieurs moyens, à vous de choisir
T'as pas Hyrule Historia à bouquiner toi ?
Ah... oui, Iro... Sacré Iro !
N'hésitez pas à aller voir la chaîne de Iro Sef,
le père de l'infini.
C'est clairement mon équivalent vivant à Lorule
Il est fan de PopCulture et il vous a préparé aussi une grosse vidéo sur Breath of the Wild 2 qui vaut le détour
Alors, foncez pour devenir un explorateur d'univers !
Aller bref, c'était Argorok, on va reparler de Zelda très bientôt et que
le Lionheart soit avec vous